how confident are you that for the folks
that are worried if they will keep the
four fully fully United on the same page
versus the government's going to try to
get the girls to break and say something
so some may look at this as a hey
they're now being released to go home
this could be seen as did they do a deal
with the government or it's Andrew and
Tristan saying no if anyone's going to
go home they're going to go home
so two different things first of all I
think absolutely it's a common both a
police and prosecution strategy to try
to divide and conquer I think
um how we refer to it here is they
always try to get the weakest link to
roll on you know the bigger Target so
absolutely I would not be surprised if
that's something that the prosecution
intends or tries to do
[Music]